switching off appliances doesn't stop
the flow of electricity your devices can
stay on indefinitely and power sapping
standby mode how much power the Belkin
conserve end site is supposed to tell
you just plug your devices into the
strip and use the included wireless
switch to be clear the inside provides
data that you never see even at the
meter it shows you the watts in real
time and how much that costs it'll even
back calculate the carbon dioxide
produced and generating all that power
you'll know exactly how much all those
standby modes are costing you and the
planet that should be just enough to win
household arguments about who's the
bigger power hog